So, the reason why I stopped where I did at lunchtime is that we're now going into
a section in which Jesus tells Louisa the difference between being resigned to the divine
will and actually living in the divine will.
That's the first one.
And then he's going to teach her the difference between true sanctity and false sanctity.
Now, unfortunately, you'll have names and addresses on the false sanctity.
So, this kind of instruction is the basic instruction that we need in our pockets going
to Valentin.
So you recognize things.
Not that you have to remember it all in your head, but it'll actually be in your heart.
And so, when things come up on that, you'll find it comes up because you've put it in.
Is that okay?
So, I want to pick up in order to obey Louisa said, in order to obey the command that was
given to her, Louisa said, "I want to say a few words about the difference between
being resigned to the divine will and living in the divine will.
Now, give yourself a heading for that paragraph so that when you need to go back to it for
reference, you don't have to say, "Well, where on earth is it, it's somewhere in volume
12?"
So, living in the divine will versus resignation is your heading.
First of all, let's take living resigned in the divine will.
According to my poor opinion, Louisa said, "This means to resign oneself to the divine
will in everything."
Now, you need to underline the everything because we might do it in 90% of the things.
Both in prosperous and in adverse circumstances.
That means that everything's fine until it's something I don't really want or something
I'm not comfortable with and I mightn't resign myself to that.
And this is where this kind of instruction is actually very important for us because
you might say, you know, in the morning I want to resign myself to God's will, then
something happens during the day and you find yourself reacting to it.
So, you discover in your experience that there was a difference between your words
and your actions.
So, whether the conditions are actually prosperous or adverse, you still accept God's will.
You look at the divine will in everything.
In other words, there's no coincidences.
There's only God incidences and whatever happens to you, it's either the direct will
of God or the permissive will of God, whichever it is.
The order of the divine dispositions, which it has over all people, such that not even
one hair can fall from our head if the Lord doesn't want it so, that's Luke 12, 7.
Every hair on your head is counted.
It seems to me like a good son who goes wherever his father wants and suffers whatever his
father wants.
So, the good son will go and will suffer whatever the father wants.
Poor or rich, it is indifferent to him, he is content only with being what the father
wants.
St. Paul says that he arrived at that point in Philippians 4, 12.
If he receives or asks for an order to go somewhere for the fulfillment of some business, he only
goes because the father wants it.
So, here's us checking out that every single thing does the Lord want it.
Is this something God actually wants?
But in the meantime, he must take some refreshments, stop and rest, have some food, deal with
people, and therefore he has to put much of his own will into it, even though he goes
because the father wanted it.
Now, that's the position that most people find themselves in when they start out on
this journey.
Like you're involved in everyday business and all the rest of it.
You want to do God's will, but in the actual detail, you may not even have checked it out
whether the Lord actually wants it.
However, in many things he finds himself in the circumstance of doing them by himself
that means not into the divine will.
How many people have even admitted, "Shri didn't even remember for the last three hours that
I should be having contact with the Lord."
You know what I mean?
So, you just get totally involved in what you're doing.
He may be far away from the father for days or months without receiving specifically of
the will of the father in all things.
So, you can slip back into ordinary thinking without even noticing.
So, for one who lives resigned to the divine will, it's almost impossible not to mix his
own will with it.
Now, that's the extremely important statement.
And you know from those of you who have studied the human will versus the divine will, that
that can be lethal.
So, if we're back at this point then, it's nearly impossible not to mix the two wills
or you can't mix the two wills to shift from one to the other.
He may be a good son, but he will not have in everything the thoughts, the words, the
life of the father fully portrayed in him.
In fact, since he has to go return, follow, deal with others, love is already broken because
only continuous union, this is the next bit you underline, only continuous union makes
love grow and it never breaks.
And the current of the will of the father is not in continuous communication with the
current of the will of the son in what we have just read.
And in those intervals, the son may get used to doing his own will.
However, I believe she said that this is actually the first step towards sanctity.
At least she's admitted there's some good in it.
So, for us trying to live in the divine will, that's a very good correction moment, you
know, to make sure am I consciously living the divine will at every moment.
Now, the second one she wants to deal with is those who actually live in the divine will.
So, these two are going to live at a much higher plane altogether.
I'd like to, the hand of my Jesus to write this, she said, he alone can tell all the
beauty, the goodness and the sanctity of living in the divine will.
I'm incapable, I have many concepts about it in my mind, but I lack the words.
My Jesus pour yourself into my word that I may say what I can.
Now, those of you doing the seminars or anything else in dramatine, there's your prayer.
Jesus I lack the ability, but I ask you to pour yourself into my word so that it's your
words that come out and not mine.
See, I told you that all the preparation was here, didn't I?
And so, living in the divine will means being inseparable.
So, there's your, your glass of water, the two sections of water cannot be separated.
No chemical process can separate them.
Why?
Because they're identical.
So, the first thing is being inseparable with the Lord.
The second thing is doing nothing by yourself.
So, this is a great deal of discernment for you today now.
Doing nothing by yourself, because before the divine will, one feels incapable of everything.
So, if you feel incapable of what you've been asked to do, that's perfectly okay.
Anyone living in the divine will has the realistic realization, none of us are capable of anything,
except sin.
Okay.
So, he does not ask for orders, nor does he receive them, because he feels incapable of
going on his own, that's John 15, 5, without me, you can do nothing.
And he says, Lord, if you want me to do this, let us, look at the plural, do it together.
There's your second answer for those doing the seminars.
Okay.
We're going to do this together.
And if you want me to go, let us go together, Philippians 4.13.
So, he does all that the father does.
Now, notice the other son went about and did his own business and all the rest of him.
He did love his father, and he did serve his father, and to some extent he did actually
obey him.
But he was living his own life as well.
So this one does all that the father does.
If the father thinks he makes the thought of the father his own, and he has not one thought
more than those of the father.
Now, that's what we've been reading about in the texts I gave you from John's gospel,
because that's what Jesus is saying.
I only do what my father tells me to do.
And he say what my father tells me to say, and so on.
But I want to give you two Corinthians 10, verses one to four.
Because in that section, St. Paul tells us that every thought must be captured and given
to Christ.
Now, if you want dependence for Lent, there you have it.
Never mind all the other things you thought you were going to do.
If you try and capture every thought and give it to Christ, you'll be fully occupied in
penance.
On this, of course, you're a saint, and then we'll congratulate you, because half the time
we don't even know we're wandering off in our own thoughts.
We don't even know we're having a dialogue with ourselves and the Lord is in dinner.
And we don't even know that we're criticizing our neighbor, and it's inside of me.
There's nothing to do with them.
Oh, it has something to do with them.
And many people think that my own thoughts are private.
They don't affect anybody else.
Your own thoughts are part of the wharf and roof of the whole planet.
They do affect everybody.
And what's even worse, your thoughts are written on your face.
Everybody knows, at least not everybody, the people who have any level of discernment
can read your eyes.
Don't you know, looking into another person's eyes, what they're thinking of you?
Yeah, of course you do.
Even a kid in the cradle gets that, and they start playing the mother of the father.
Before they're walking, they learn how to read faces, and they learn how to read eyes.
Okay.
Yeah, your thoughts are on your, on your, your, and if you want to know what people think
of you, I got this in a couple of classes I did on psychology many years ago.
I don't remember half of what they told, but I remember a couple of things.
One of the things they said was, if you want to find out what people think of somebody
in the room, all you do is let that person go out the door, and then let them come in
and see the reaction of everybody.
Now most of them will try to hide their reaction, but to see it on their face, not again, annoyed
that the person went out and come in, but they're not going to say anything because
they're too polite, but it's on their face, and sometimes it's just, it's just an expression
or it's a stiffening of the body or whatever it is.
Everything that's in the mind has been expressed, and they actually did some experiments with
this, it was hilariously funny because you actually did read everybody's thoughts.
So when you read in the gospel that Jesus read everybody's thoughts, there was nothing,
there was nothing.
He knew how to read their bodies as well.
So capturing every thought and giving it to Christ is a major operation.
You won't know that unless you try it.
If the father looks, if he speaks, if he works, if he walks, if he suffers, if he loves,
he too looks at what the father looks at, repeats the words of the father, works with
the hands of the father, walks with the feet of the father, suffers with the same pains
as the father, and loves with the same love as the father.
That means total commitment with the word total underlined.
In what I've just read, there's absolutely no room for self, none whatsoever.
He lives not outside, but inside the father, and therefore he is the reflection and the
perfect portrait of the father that's 2 Corinthians 3, 18.
I also want to give you Hebrews 1, 3.
Hebrews 1, 3 says that Jesus is the icon of the father, and we are supposed to be the
icon of Jesus.
But all his interior is as though interwoven with the interior of the father transformed,
dissolved completely and European, completely in God.
That's Ephesians 4, 23.
Now notice they dissolved, and the word completely is repeated because the Lord knows us very
well.
I can't usually quote anything from the higher volumes, that is over volume 20, but there
is one bit, and I don't know, it may be volume 23, where the Lord says, "Make sure your
nothingness is empty."
Now that really went through me, and I remembered it, and I said, "You know us, very well."
It's like we drink a cup of tea, and if you take the cup from the person to go and wash
it, this little drop of tea is still left in it, it's not completely taken.
The little tiny drop of coffee is still in the cup, it's not completely taken.
They're not completely given.
There's something inside of us that says, "Well you know I have to survive, you know,
and I have to give a tiny little bit for myself."
Now that tiny little bit ensures you won't ever be canonized.
And then Louisa goes on, "Oh the rapid and sublime flights of this child into the divine
will.
Divine volition is immense, watch this now, in every instant it circulates in every person.
The divine will gives life to everything and orders everything.
And the soul moving within this immensity flies into all souls and helps all souls,
loves all souls, but as Jesus himself helps and loves, that's John 1334.
You do it the way Jesus does it, not the way human beings do things.
And after he has done everything he says, "I have done nothing, Jesus did it."
Now I should have the reference for that, but I'm lazy and I haven't.
All I know is it's in Luke 17, we're only unprofitable servants.
Do you remember when the work is all done?
And this is all my contentment, that miserable as I am, Jesus has given me the honor to keep
me in his divine will, to let me do what he himself has done.
If we ever grasp the enormity of the privilege, we'll do it.
So the enemy cannot bother this child.
Now why can't the enemy bother this child?
Because this child is in the divine will and the devil can't touch the divine will.
But up to the time when we're living fully and completely in the divine will, the enemy
can attack, because we're not completely there, do you get it?
Now you know this better than I do, because you've reared children.
So you know that a child hides themselves behind the couch, but they leave the leg out
to make sure you know that they're actually there.
They're not completely hidden, they're not completely hidden.
Okay, so it's the ones who are completely in the divine will, that the enemy can't
get at them.
The other ones with the leg out, just for safety sake, they can be attacked.
So the enemy can't bother the child in the divine will.
Whether he has done well or badly little or much, because Jesus himself did everything.
Now there's a slight contradiction in that sentence, whether you did badly or good little
or much, because Jesus did everything, Jesus doesn't do anything badly.
So what you're saying is whether you perceive that you yourself have not done well, in fact
it is well, because Jesus has done it.
Is that okay?
It's like me and the IT, I never do it well, do you know what I mean?
These machines drive me crazy.
But the Lord helps, and so you manage to get a recording in spite of me.
So he does everything well, he does everything together with Jesus.
Now Jesus is the most peaceful one, he is peace.
Now I would have to give you far too many references in the Bible for that.
You know that on the day he was born, that he was introduced as the Prince of Peace.
Okay, so he is not subject to anxiety.
Look at this now, and it appears on the surface as a contradiction.
He loves no one and he loves everyone.
What does that mean?
It means he has no attachments.
You see, we can say we love somebody, but an actual fact we're either holding on to
them or depending on them or whatever else.
So the attachment means you're not really loving them objectively in their own shoes,
letting them being their own unique persons.
He does.
He actually allows each one of us to be our own unique selves and he loves everyone.
But he loves them on a divine level.
It's not a human level.
It can be said that he is, sorry, pardon me, we're now talking about the soul in the divine
will who will behave like Jesus, who will love without attachment, okay?
And therefore you will love people in their own shoes and you will discover the uniqueness
of each person.
And I think that's the wonder of being a divine will family, that the uniqueness of
each person is allowed to express itself and that you love the uniqueness of each person.
And therefore there's enormous variety and there's enormous interest as well, but there's
no clinging on to anybody.
Is that okay?
So we're doing in the divine will what Jesus did himself on the earth.
And so we're loving people divinely.
Now this is the unconditional love that you'll hear more about.
It can be said that this soul is the repeater of the life of Jesus, the organ of his voice.
That means that if you have to speak at any level with people, giving seminars or talks
or classes or anything else, that you simply push yourself aside and ask the Lord to come
through and he will.
He comes through in the most extraordinary way.
I mean I've had the experience of, because I've been doing this for years, specifically
sometimes I would do it with my body just so that I'd remind myself that I'm pushing
myself aside to let the Lord come through.
And there have been times when I was speaking publicly and the words that came out of my
mouth were changed as they came out of my mouth.
I was saying, I was hoping to say something and the people heard something else.
And I remember I'm on one of these occasions, I was really struck by what came out and I
said, oh, that's interesting.
The people said, you saying that and I said, well that's the first time I heard this.
Because it can be very exciting then, you know, because you can be trying or hoping
to say something, say in a seminar or a teaching or something and you just say to the Lord,
you come through, you do it, because I continuously say to the Lord, they don't want to hear me.
If they had you teaching them, do you think I would get a look in, forget about it.
Don't.
It's you they want, so I push myself aside and you come through.
So you become the repeater of the life of Jesus, the organ of his voice, the heartbeat
of his heart and the sea of his grace as you become the source of grace for so many people.
Isn't that just incredible?
True sanctity, now we're going on to true sanctity and false sanctity.
We have just been through whether you are really in the divine will or you're simply
resigned to it.
So true sanctity, I believe, consists only in this.
All other things are only shadows, larvae, I think using that word is absolutely extraordinary.
Specters of sanctity.
In other words, people can be going around dressed in all kinds of religion and attending
all kinds of services and everything, but there might be no sanctity.
Because if there's no real love and there's no gift of themselves and if there's no sacrifice,
then all you have is religion and religion can be dangerous.
Very interesting and you need to know that the devil doesn't mind you having religion.
He only minds if you love.
He only minds if you're prepared to sacrifice yourself.
He only minds if you're going to really surrender to God.
He does mind that and he'll try and stop it because that's the real thing.
So in the divine will, virtues take their place in the divine order, not in the human order.
But outside it in the human order, they're subject to self-esteem, vain glory and passions.
For example, someone said to me not so long ago, "You must have felt a bit of pride about
that."
I said, "Pardon?"
Just because I had done well with something.
Do you know what I mean?
I said, "But we live in a no place place, we're living in a down there in the nothing
this place."
I said, "There's no room for pride in nothingness."
If you know anything about nothingness, there's no room for pride.
For pride you need to lift your head up to exalt yourself.
But you see, it's where we're coming from, it's the world we're coming out of.
And so people think, "You know, I'm the great me because I'm the great healer or I'm the
great teacher."
I wouldn't say it, you know what I mean?
But their behavior tells you that that's what they think.
And nobody can do this except me, you know?
So there's the self-esteem, vain glory.
That's glory given to yourself, not God.
And to passions, they're all the emotions allowed to express themselves.
Oh, how many good works and how many attended sacraments are to be cried over before God
and to be repaired for because they are empty of divine will.
And therefore they are without fruits.
I once heard a Protestant preacher speak about church attendees as pure warmers.
I've never forgotten it because he was trying to say to them, "The fact that you
attend church or you attend something religious does not mean that anything in you has surrendered
to God."
So you're only a pure farmer.
It's deaf-rightening.
Now, Louise is saying the same thing just in her own language.
So let's look at it.
How many good works?
That means you've gone to Africa helping concern or troker or something, you know what I mean?
How many attended sacraments are to be cried over before God and to be repaired for because
they are empty of divine will.
They're going for any reason on the planet except God's will.
You want to be seen at a funeral, but you're not going to worship God and you're not going
to pray for the dead and they are without fruits.
Heaven willing that all would comprehend or understand true sanctity or how all other
things would disappear.
So now she's going to talk about pious practices so fasten your seatbelts.
Therefore, many find themselves on the false way of sanctity.
Many place sanctity in pious practices, now the translation has a duplicate, a pious practices
of piety.
So that's a contradiction in English, just pious practices.
That means they've put all sanctity in novenas and pilgrimages and going to holy places and
lightened candles and God knows what else they do, okay.
They place sanctity in these practices and woo to those who move them.
Now to illustrate that I have to explain something that happened to me in Canada.
When I was traveling around the world speaking in churches, I always asked the priest to
open the church very early in the morning so that I could have a bit of time to pray
before the crowds came.
Most of them did it, some of them didn't, and most of them did it.
In this particular church, I was praying all alone, there wasn't another soul, there was
only the blessed sacrament in myself, and we were getting on, fine.
And my eyes closed and I was totally interior, never noticed somebody coming into the church.
This thing, I got an almighty dig in my right arm.
Get out of there, that's my place.
And I looked up and there was this angry woman arriving early for her prayers and I said,
the church is empty.
"That's my place," she said, and so I made second attempt, then I gave up.
I said to her, "Jesus is here, I got up, I went as far from her as I could get."
Do you see the contradiction?
This is what Louisa is talking about, that some people can really fool themselves that
they are getting close to God when in actual fact they're not.
She was so stuck to that tiny spot.
I mean, how was I supposed to know?
Anyway, never mind.
I don't know what she thought when I got up to give the talk.
Or she said how they deceived themselves.
If their wills are not united with Jesus and also transformed in him, which is continuous
prayer.
The continuous prayer is 24/7, 365.
It's not one hour in the day because prayer is communion with God and communion doesn't
have to be with words.
It's continuous prayer with all their pious practices, their sanctity is false, they're
deceiving themselves.
Now you see, the devil doesn't mind you going to church.
He doesn't mind you doing all kinds of practices.
He only minds if you surrender to God's will.
And if you sacrifice yourself to love others that you're really giving, that you're prepared
to love, that's what he minds.
He doesn't mind the other stuff.
And it shows how these souls pass very easily from pious practices to defects.
So I'm attacked with anger and I'm attacked physically as well in the church because I'm
in the spot that she's stuck to.
And they pass very easily from this to amusements.
Now I had the very interesting experience of someone who came to my classes.
I won't give you any more detail because the island is too small.
And this person or persons in the plural were presenting themselves as very holy, very
pious people and all the rest of it.
And I just, I don't know how it happened, but I just got into conversation with them
anyway and asked them what they were doing for Lent.
And we're going on a world tour for Lent.
So I smiled and I said, "Have a good day."
For Lent, and they were going on a luxury cruise.
I said, "Why don't you wait on the Easter," because I didn't hear that.
So they pass rather quickly from pious practices to defects, to amusements, to the sowing of
discord, and other things.
I'm glad she didn't tell us what the other things were.
All how dishonored is this kind of sanctity.
So that's that one.
So the second example she gives you are others place sanctity in going to church, attending
all the services, but their will is far from Jesus.
And it shows how these souls have little care for their own duties.
Now we have it.
So here's someone who will attend everything that's going on in the church, but they're
not available to their spouse, and they're not available to their children, and they're
not carrying out their duties.
And one of the aspects of God's will for every single person on the planet is to carry out
the duties of your state and life.
So they are putting the emphasis entirely on the wrong thing.
And you know that if the parent is missing from the home when they're small children,
it doesn't matter whether the parent is doing good or bad, the children will suffer desperately
because the parent is missing.
And if these people are hindered, they get angry, they cry that their sanctity goes up
in the air.
They lament, they disobey, and they are the wounds of the family.
So you can see that their lives are in disorder, because disorder has been described perfectly
there.
"Oh, what false sanctity," she said.
Now the next example she's going to give us is not really belonging to our age, but
it was definitely a problem in Louisa's time when Louisa's time therefore is early 20th
century.
And apparently the thing was you were supposed to have a spiritual director, and you were
supposed to tell your sins in my new detail.
And you're supposed to go over them and over them, I couldn't even imagine it.
It's like instead of putting the clothes on the washing machine and getting rid of the
stuff and getting it dried and in fact that you examine every minute detail in every garment.
I don't know if you'd be able for that.
No, I wouldn't.
So she says, "others place their sanctity in frequent confessions."
Now the frequent confessions here include spiritual direction.
So since confession is not all that popular at the moment, this doesn't apply as much
to us as it did to them.
In minute spiritual direction, in other words giving minute details, that means they want
to massage all their feelings and all their thoughts and all their words and all their
actions.
So literally on a spiritual level, a self-massage, sorry for the language, in minute spiritual
direction and having scruples about everything, that's what I mean by your examining everything
in my new detail, but then they have no scruple that their will does not run together with
the will of Jesus.
And woe to those who can't predict them, you see you'll always know if somebody is doing
their own will, anybody else supposing them and you're in trouble.
These souls are like inflated balloons.
I love that expression.
Let me give you a different expression which will help you to laugh, windbags, windbags,
because you know if you put a pin in the balloon, you've got a big bang and that's all.
These are like inflated balloons, she said, "a little hole is enough for the air to come
out and their sanctity goes up in smoke and it falls to the ground."
These poor windbags have always something to say.
They are mostly inclined to sadness and otherwise they give out about everything.
I don't know what you do when you meet somebody where everything is all bad and not everything
is terrible and they're only telling you negative stuff about absolutely everything.
I just say have a good day, because you couldn't cure them because they're enjoying it, they're
mostly inclined to sadness and they live always in doubt and therefore they'd like to have
a director for themselves who would advise them, give them peace and console them, that's
a big bit now, in every little thing.
But they are soon agitated just as they were before, poor sanctity, how forged it is.
Luke 724, now you've got three different reactions of people to religion here and all
of them is false and the reason why they're all false is that the person is absolutely
locked up in self-love.
They're not committed to God's will, they're not committed to unconditional love, they're
not committed to sacrifice and so on.
So, Louisa said I would like the tears of my Jesus to cry together with him over these
false sanctities and make everyone know how true sanctity is doing God's will.
Green, white and gold, underline.
True sanctity is utterly and completely simple.
There's no complication and in actual fact you need no spiritual director because it's
surrendering to God's will and living in unconditional love, that's it.
You're home and dry, you got it.
So, I'd like to make everyone know how true sanctity is in doing God's will and in living
in the divine will.
This sanctity sinks its roots so deep that there's no danger that they will oscillate.
Now, you know the oscillation is the reed blowing in the wind, do you remember?
Because it fills earth and heaven and everywhere it fills its support, it finds its support.
This soul is firm, now there's your fortitude again.
Not subject to inconstancy nor to voluntary defects, now what you got underline is voluntary.
We all have defects, but an involuntary defect is not a problem, a voluntary defect is.
Now, are you sure you know the difference between the two?
Okay, I usually take whoever's on my right or on my left as an example, supposing this
person bumps into me at a time when I'm over tired and I'm a bit fragile and I react.
That's an involuntary defect because I reacted because of my tiredness and blah, blah, blah.
I just can't take anymore.
But if I want to pull her down, if I want to give her a piece of my mind, now I'm into
voluntary defects.
If you're into voluntary defects, no divine will, it's as simple as that.
Involuntary defects, very easy to deal with and the Lord is totally compassionate.
You're a human and who man him, Esther, Ari, it's human to her.
So he doesn't have a problem with involuntary defects.
Human beings do.
Look at the way she's reacting to stop and they don't take into account that at that
particular moment you actually couldn't take anymore.
The cup was overflowing, okay, but the Lord has no problem with it like that, okay.
So this person is consistent, has no voluntary defects.
She's attentive to her duties.
Remember one of the false sanctities there in the church but they weren't at home doing
anything that they should do?
She is most sacrificed, now all the other false, actually it would be very good if you
got two pieces of paper and wrote down all the things she says about false sanctity and
all the things she says about true sanctity and you have it.
The false sanctities don't sacrifice themselves.
They're indulging themselves even when they get spiritual direction.
The true sanctity is detached from everyone, in other words, I'm not drawing out of another
human being in order for me to live, is that okay?
So I'm detached from everything, I'm also not leaning on a thing.
The only example I can give you of leaning on a thing is I remember speaking to a certain
gentleman some years ago and he was driving a rather large car as in a Rolls Royce.
Now he did have to have money to get it and everything but never mind.
I said to him, "Why do you need a large luxurious car?
All we need is four wheels under us to get us from A to B and depending on what territory
you're in you might need a stronger car or a lighter car."
He said, "Woman," he said, "You have no idea what you're talking about."
I said, "Tell me," he said, "This is better than having an affair."
I said, "You're poor, so..."
Not only can you not take a material thing with you when you go to the real place but
you can't take the attachment either.
I said, "You're poor, soul."
I said, "Me, you're poverty-stricken."
And he looked at me, of course, as if I had come out with a mentor.
We have to be detached from every one and everything, even from directions themselves.
That is something that might be very strange to you.
And Louisa is speaking in the early 20th century when people were so attached to their
spiritual directors, and I go to Father, so and so, and my spiritual director is better
than yours.
You've heard four-year-old saying, "My daddy's better than yours, haven't you?"
Okay, so you know the spiritual age then.
And Louisa says, "You have to be detached even from the directions themselves."
But Louisa had a whole squad of spiritual directors.
She didn't ask further what the Lord insisted on her having them, and she said, "You even
have to be free of what they tell you.
You only do God's will."
Now, if you have grasped anything in these writings up to Volume 12, you realize that
none of the priests who were spiritual directors to Louisa could tell her where this thing was
going because none of them had ever heard of divine will.
They couldn't.
All they could do was help her at the level that they were at, and that's why a lot of
the time they caused her a lot of pain.
And she had to discern the difference between the level that they were speaking at and the
level that the Lord was operating with her.
So you've even got to be free of that.
You've got to be free of everything.
Well, the way the other saints put it is, "Hold life lightly."
And you're illustrated by your fingers, your hand up, and your fingers all free so that
water will run through your fingers.
Hold life lightly.
And Saint Therese of Lesus said, "That you go to God empty-handed every day so that he
will fill it.
But if I'm holding on to all the stuff of the past, then there's no space in my hand
for anything else."
So if I'm attached to the stuff of the past, I can't be open to what's being given to me
now.
So you've got to be detached from everyone and from everything, even from directions themselves.
And since the roots are deep, she rises so high.
Now the image I would give you for that, well, first of all, it's a tree.
You know that if a tree grows to a great height, it's supposed to have that level of canopy
underground as well to support it, and if it doesn't have, it'll come down in a storm.
But the higher the buildings go up, the deeper the roots have got to go down, the foundations
have to go down.
And if the foundations are not deep, there's no point in building a high building.
And spiritually, if our foundations are now deep into humility and nothingness and freedom
from self and all the rest of it, if our roots are not down there, there's no point in building
because the first storm will knock you down.
So the roots are so deep that she rises so high and the flowers and fruits bloom in heaven.
So the image she has is of a growing thing.
And she's so hidden in God, that's Deuteronomy 32, 12.
The Lord alone is her guide.
Deuteronomy 32, 12.
She's so hidden in God that the earth sees little or nothing of this soul.
Now, Louisa is speaking about very advanced stage of union in the divine will here.
And since we're only on the journey to this place, you might not appreciate that the deeper
you get into the divine will, the less you want to be involved out there.
And what's out there is a completely different plane altogether where you're at.
And you'll find yourself estranged also from people outside because they're dealing with
life at a level that is so low.
Recently I listened to a humbling.
And as I was listening to it, I just said to the Lord, compared to what I'm hearing,
I live on a planet in a galacty far away.
There was no connection.
There wasn't even anything just language connected.
Because you're either in the divine will or you're not.
So one of the things that we have to acknowledge is where am I and where do I want to be?
Now the world and everything that's in it is pulling you right down to where they're at.
The demon wants to keep you pulled down to where they're at.
The Lord wants to lift you up.
You have to decide whether you are going there and whether you're going to stay there because
it's a decision at every single moment of your day.
It's actually a continuous decision.
And gradually you'll get to the place where you're there.
But there are certain signs that you will know that you're there.
And that is that you actually don't have a need to go places and do things and experience
things like other people because it belongs to a different realm to you, it belongs to
a different world.
And all your need for going, well I am reading this many years ago, my get up and go has got
up and went.
But I actually don't want it.
You've arrived if I can put it the other way.
So I'm going to stop in a minute because I'm over my time but I need to finish this sentence.
So the world knows little or nothing about this person, they just think you're just wasting
your life.
That's grand.
So they pay no attention to you.
The divine will keeps her absorbed within itself.
Now Louisa is giving you a perfect description of herself.
See Jesus is the author, the life, the form of this sanctity, of this enviable creature.
She has nothing of her own but everything is in common with Jesus.
Her passion is the divine will.
In other words, what makes you tick?
What is it that sort of tells us what you live for?
Her passion is the divine will.
Her characteristic is the will of her Jesus and the fiat is her continuous motto.
I'm going to stop there.
Is that absolutely wonderful?